walk over to this video I've lost a
couple of seconds here because I screwed
up the screen size it's still a bit bit
off but okay I should be able to play
with couple of seconds down I lost the
first game of this view a challenge and
the only appropriate measure sh4 I want
to revenge for this game I was
completely winning already and then I'm
so I simply didn't pay any attention to
um an attack on my g6 porn had lost and
it was not so much the born it was a
deadly attack on the king okay I caught
up on the clock the h4 line is doing his
job yeah it's quite funny um I recently
watched the video Peter sweet love the
work number one expert on the gruene
felt and he says he said that he
considers h4 to be a serious serious
business and that he recommends 55 c 6
against it one of them all more passive
passive approaches you know this is
certainly not a refutation for from
blackboard of you I mean what has a
comfortable position here let's see I
can I can do many things here the bishop
here maybe h5 that's already some
pressure he cannot really castle here
Queen age six is some quite quite a
nuisance and I'm threatening to take
he can castle this is a statement okay
so Queen age 6 what are you doing after
that Queen f6 probably but then I'm
checkmating with Queen takes f8 oh this
is beautiful let's see yeah maybe yes
Queen check or something that's really
cute Queen f6 queen of a check king of a
drug see a check in g7 h6 checkmate
that's really nice don't see that too
often and I've got I've got 95 I mean oh
please play Queen f6 I want to want to
play this mate and it's not so clear
what else should he do a man he can't
play Queen a 5 but whoopsies Rhea it's
not really it's not really a move i 95
is a big threat I mean what should he do
c6
hmm okay unfortunately now this is not
and i cannot i cannot play this mating
combination now which is really a shame
but still let's let's just fall for a
moment i mean i can just take a take g5
isn't this a win you know i probably is
now really has no defense threatening me
for orgy form so just attack the queen
the only thing i must must be cautious
off not not blundering again like in the
first game can easily happen even in
this overwhelming position okay let's
see rook c5 if he's got the check it's
not a winning and there is no hmm hm
i I don't I mean okay i don't i don't
see a better move at the moment that
Knight f3 which is a bit bit pedestrian
but ok it's not not bad of course ok
next one g4 maybe or just develop now
come on let's just develop ok Queen
chennai before i'll look h3 look h 3 2
g-3 and speed this is pretty strong run
yeah check no it is not strong what the
what the heck am I doing here I don't
get it I really don't get it what am I
doing here
ah why did that just play 3some normal
move this would have one really easily
and what is this now no idea I at least
96 of the big threat I think black is
still in its in substantial trouble my
morning check don't see a mate though
didn't see a maid we give the check I've
got Roxy one that's important check
check check check
three surprising that there's no no
checkmate Jack it cannot play rock t 1
and this is a comedy this this game when
both of them really are the first one
offer was the was quite similar I cannot
go to a three now what the what the heck
Jack yeah this happens if you relax too
early it's just a just terrible white
forfeits on time dence was probably a
plus 11 plus 12 position and I just done
didn't didn't really my brain really
stopped working look rook h3 is just
should be shot for this nonsense I mean
every move wins everything a three wins
III wins everything winds not rogue age
30 man yeah well and this is frustrating
this is just frustrating I mean here I
mean castles is just insane sorry this
is an insane move g5 and no it's it's
basically resigns but not if your
opponent plays rook age three yeah here
it was quite quite funny that this is
leading to a check my head check
checkmate and so I did see some lines up
to this point but here garruk a dream
and I was just trying to get this over
with quickly but you can you can do
anything I mean maybe this this kind of
move is good after Queen a5 I mean I
don't need to necessarily meet you
something like this is just just a pawn
and a better position
so you can win yeah and the way it was
played as buzz was again totally winning
yeah because this is a this is again now
of course a win for white but it's not
not clear-cut I guess yeah okay here he
for the reason for some reason could
escape and now it's a now it's very
tricky what is this five against four
yeah and the move I played now was was
just crazy this one and this was
probably okay I'd like to give checks
but the round here it gets it gets weird
it's very strange this position you can
always here always has those kind of
check seein ya it's really know it's not
easy to play the some stuff and TM just
lost him I'm just lost because after age
six i cannot i cannot interpose anymore
which I overlooked so I lost this visual
challenge to zero out of two completely
winning positions yeah what can you do
now it's not so easy I I always have
some problems to switch time controls I
played a couple of 15-minute games
before and this does not seem to help I
don't know but Jeff but can you do
alright thanks for watching